Welcome back everyone this will be my full marvel
thor love and thunder post credit scene video and
breakdown of the ending of the movie there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs obviously they set
up a bunch of really big things in the future
of marvel phase four like you would expect post
credit scenes to do so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing a giveaway for imax tickets
for the movie all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and just post all your theories
about the future of the thor character in the mcu
i'll name a giveaway winner later in the video
too but careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the movie yet we're obviously talking about
the post-credits scenes in the end of the movie
but at the very end of the movie thor
and jane foster are able to convince gorr
to wish for his daughter to come back to life this
is happening at the center of the universe there's
a bunch of cosmic concepts that you saw in all
the trailers eternity is meant to represent the
living embodiment of the universe itself so like
there's a version of eternity for every single
universe that's why its body is depicted as the
star field like you're looking at the universe
and when they travel to the space where eternity
actually lives where it exists it's meant to be
this very abstract place because it's an abstract
concept because when they're in this place looking
at eternity they're looking at everything in
the universe but they themselves are kind of
still in the universe so they're kind of looking
at themselves like a little tiny point here in
the center of eternity all the cosmic entities
that they feature here at the end of the movie
are meant to be incredibly powerful being some
of them more powerful than others for some of
them they're different versions in every single
universe and for some of them there's only one
for the entire multiverse like there's only one
living tribunal for the entire multiverse even
though he's depicted here as one of the lesser
beings from eternity they want to make eternity
seem like it's the most powerful being in this
universe that usually depends on which writer
is talking about the characters you don't see the
character eternity in a whole lot of stories but
the entire movie hinges on this big plot point
that gorr thinks that you can go to eternity
and the first person who reaches it like actually
gets this abstract place and can speak to it can
make a wish and it will grant it and that's it
they kind of treat it like a one-time use only
kind of genie first person gets the wish as if no
being has ever actually made it to eternity before
but all the mcu gods know how to find it it's like
the secret amongst all the gods but in the comics
eternity is meant to be nigh omnipotent in each
of their own universes they have control over all
matter time and space so theoretically they could
grant any kind of wish or anything that you ask
of it but they're not like a one-time use only
kind of genie and they usually don't care about
the day-to-day of lesser beings so like even if
you were gorr and you were able to reach eternity
it would probably just not listen to you like it
probably wouldn't care what you had to say to it
and even in the comics as powerful as gorr gets
and he gets way more powerful than he is in the
movie it still didn't seem like in the gorr comics
he was able to kill cosmic entities like that like
he really just wanted to go after the gods so in
the movie eternity was kind of like a proxy for
the god bomb plot which was the end of the gorr
comic storyline and that was sort of like gorge
thanos level infinity gauntlet plan like okay
instead of going around balancing all pantheons
one at a time in the slow way i'm gonna kill
every single god with a bomb all at the same
time so in the movie gorr initially was going
to use his wish to wish that there were no gods
and yes eternity would be powerful enough to do
something like that to like snap its fingers and
make all gods go away as if they never existed
but they convinced gorr to wish for his daughter
to come back to life and in the movie she's played
by chris hemsworth's real life daughter that's why
she speaks with an australian accent and christian
bale's gorr speaks with a welsh accent the reason
why she has the powers of a god seemingly why she
seems so strong is because when she comes back to
life the way they explain in the movie at least is
that it's a side effect of her being recreated by
eternity itself that's why she's able to wield
stormbreaker without it melting her brain
thor agrees to raise and protect her as gorr lays
dying along with jane foster and even though she's
a god thor treats her like his daughter like
she doesn't really need anyone to protect her
if she's that powerful korg has a line at the end
of the movie where he calls them love and thunder
like they're known as love and thunder because
her name is supposed to be love at the very end
of the movie they explained that they just go on
adventures around the universe helping out lesser
races of beings doing the same thing that you saw
thor doing with the guardians of the galaxy at the
beginning of the movie just answering distressed
calls randomly all over the universe not just in
the nine realms and because jane foster has died
thor starts wielding mule near again the reforged
mjolnir and she wields stormbreaker korg winds up
getting married to another member of his race and
they pay off this big joke about how cronin's
reproducing volcanoes over the period of like
a month implying that he's going to have a new
child there are a lot of children in this movie
in fact a big part of the plot revolves around a
giant group of children including heindall's son
astrid who turns out heimdall had a son i don't
think they've referenced that in previous movies
or even him having a wife his son astrid basically
has the same powers as heimdall a bunch of the
asgardian children are captured by gorr and he
uses them to force thor to use the bifrost to open
the portal to eternity one of the children is also
meant to be a lycan which i think is meant to help
set up the big halloween special with werewolf by
night like we're gonna start seeing werewolves and
vampires in the mcu because the new blade movie
and werewolf by night when they rescue all the
children and bring them back like there's a new
monument to jane foster's version of thor who
they just call mighty thor that's the name of the
comic book where she debuted mighty thor valkyrie
forces all the asgardian children to go through
fight training every day there's a scene with sif
who now only has one arm because gorr cut one of
them off with the necro sword training heimdall's
son astrid who now has basically gained the powers
of heimdall basically can do the same thing that
heimdall does heimdall's big power is basically
being able to see the entire universe but he has
to focus on it so like he doesn't see everything
all simultaneously you have to tell him you're
looking for something and he can see it across the
universe that's how he was able to contact thor
earlier in the movie he was able to use his power
to do that there's a couple other minor easter
eggs and references during this last little bit of
the movie that i'll cover in my full breakdown of
the entire film but the first big post credits
scene is of russell crowe zeus having survived
thor running him through with his own lightning
bolt through the chest he also revealed that his
lightning bolt weapon is called thunder this is
still taking place at omnipotent city he basically
says that it's a special protected place that
the gods can hide out so that's why they're not
worried about gorr the god butcher killing all the
gods like oh we'll be safe here in omnipotent city
valkyrie doesn't seem like she gave thunder
back to the greek gods after the ending like
they still have the thunder weapon in new asgard
they still have his lightning bolt basically there
are a couple of jokes during the movie that thor
tells about how he modeled a lot of himself after
zeus because he's the god of lightning and thor's
the god of thunder bazoo says that because mortals
no longer worship the gods in the same way they're
not afraid of them they don't seem like they care
about them at all like they used to in ancient
times and instead people pray to superheroes which
is mostly an avengers reference like regular
people worship superheroes like the avengers
especially since they saved half the universe so
he vows that he and the other gods not just the
greek gods but all gods are going to cause people
to fear the gods again starting off with them
killing thor by ordering his son hercules from
the comics played by brett goldstein obviously
probably seen hercules in some of the more recent
comics telling him to go kill thor like he says
make thor odinson fall from the sky and the people
will believe in us again but the idea is that the
gods plan on killing all the other big superheroes
like the new avengers that will form eventually
like an avengers endgame situation versus the
gods thor and hercules are both very similar
characters very similar personalities they spent
a lot of time adventuring together so thor would
know hercules in the comics hercules has also been
part of several avengers teams across the years
he's had some big arcs like during kang war which
happened pretty recently and a really huge arc
even more recently called the chaos war where he
became the god of gods that's basically like a
title you give to someone who is like the most
powerful god thor's also kind of done versions
of that too like rune king thor would be like the
god of gods when he is rune king thor but the way
they play the hercules scene it seems like it's
more of a teaser trying to set up the gods versus
the new avengers like earlier in the movie thor
says all the guys are going to hate them because
of what they did in omnipotent city not just
the greek gods but all gods and that seems
like a totally different story arc that they're
trying to set up from the incursions in the secret
wars multiverse arc so they can pay off the gods
versus the avengers in a totally separate movie
the real big infinity saga level arc that it seems
like we're in right now is the secret wars arc so
that feels like where all the attention is and all
this god tier avengers end game situation stuff
seems like a completely separate thing the second
post-credits scene is jane foster who's died
entering valhalla which is an alternate dimension
where the consciousness of all asgardians go
depending on their actions during life like they
have a couple jokes about how you actually make
it into valhalla but like valhalla is meant to
be the asgardian's version of heaven it's part
of the nine realms the reason why jane foster goes
to valhalla is because of her time as mighty thor
heimdall is there to welcome her the gates he's
guarding them just like he guarded the bifrost in
life so the idea is that thor can still now speak
to jane foster across dimensions under special
circumstances like her living essence is still
alive theoretically in this alternate dimension
it's just that she's in a different state of
existence and it requires really special means
for him to communicate with her the movies really
play it fast and loose with the rules about how
that happens and like how you actually make it
back from different dimensions like that moonite
is a really good example that like he traveled
to the dubois because he died and his spirit came
back to the world of the living like he literally
traveled back to the main mcu dimension but he
was only able to do that with a little bit of help
from the god that ruled over that dimension osiris
they could also use that as part of this plot with
the god tier version of avengers end game was zeus
and the other gods going after the avengers and
all the other mortals if you have any other big
questions about the post-credits scenes just write
them in the comments below there's like a billion
things that we need to talk about i'll be doing
a much bigger breakdown and easter egg video for
the entire movie that'll post saturday morning so
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that congratulations john mark foster
the third you're the giveaway winner for my last
big marvel video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for that full thor love and
thunder breakdown and easter eggs for the entire
movie i'll update the link as soon as i post
that and click here for my brand new marvel
daredevil video to learn about what's going on
with him the next time he shows up in the mcu
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!